I like that
[Music]
if the hallway were to ever have smoke
in the hallway and you guys head around
and use this you can't see it these
powers out the building yeah I'm gonna
have a light in this room okay
that's on 24/7 it never goes off should
anything happen nobody has to worry
about looking for a light it's turn on
it's already permanently on people can
see the fire lab
we're a go son man what are you doing ah
is that red snap any reason why you're
in here that could ask the same thing to
you I'm just uh it's not Brett's hat
you know everyone had their place here
in the office oh he's got his little
beard everyone's got beers I have a mini
beard until Ben had to come in with that
beautiful mustache I I can't grow a
mustache yeah I know
you know I've been doing some research
I've been uh thrown around some of the
old body parts that were cloned and
discarded a lot of them have some pretty
good neural links that I've been putting
Oh what do you doing man we're just
filming a tutorial oh cool uh he doesn't
weird right now I was able to actually
utilize a good third of the brain from
number flip dude add from 50 so I was
able to actually extract the neural link
from that last third of his brain and I
weaved it into this hat right we'll
never know but in theory it should be
able to control him the first test I
actually did didn't really go as planned
he became a little bit too cliche Bret's
he actually spelled out son on the paper
so this time I'm trying to ease into it
a little bit more I just gave him one
simple command to take care of Ben's
beard maybe they can have some sort of
competition I don't know
see I just I I set the inputs and I let
it play so at the end of the day I
haven't really harmed him I haven't
influenced anyone uh yeah you have no
water second spot for a fire
extinguisher or over in that corner or
maybe even in here whatever is the most
obvious easy accessible to get to
I think that's interesting yeah oh that
was operant FX the dog walking on grass
so it is like here that job let me hear
that that room okay because I got one
yeah that sounds like a dog dude yeah
you know that uh well we let cats eat
sir okay in that case yeah my are
extinguished sure is gonna go right here
I bought three extra so and just want to
make sure that why not just get an extra
one here but no I'm just checking out
the computer see me see what the
internal components are I find myself
feeling really handy lately so I want to
like you know meso stuff take it tinker
that kind of stuff I'm hacking into the
mainframe right now
is your manhood down there has been
trying to find man whose is this is this
oh wow
Wow then you've never been down there if
I was gonna give you I was going to give
you a break today Brett but I see that's
not that can't happen any longer so uh
that's
for tonight that's John's Mavic I found
this on the phantom for like a week ago
Oh Johnny you got a Mavic yeah give me
buzzy don't be shy sexy so it's it's
important to clarify this is not
corridors Mavic and this is not my Matic
my Maddox come in tomorrow so I'm very
jealous that he's good
first the cool thing about these props
is that they're hinged and you're like
oh but if they're hinged how does it fly
well with the centripetal force of it
going so fast around they become very
very stiff outwards you might want to
take the lens cover off
come on help almost there nervous stop
rushing me okay
and I am oh dude Nick you sucked on it
you float on it
there's only cover for the gimbal look
what you did I'm sorry Justin
you can't even properly get angry
because he's piloting us crunch man I'm
sorry as long as the Maverick
doesn't get crushed I'm okay
hey I'm pretty good I have it on
beginner mode so I just reached the
flight distance here okay so mines
coming in tomorrow morning and I cannot
wait to stress the hell out of it I want
to take it up to the top of mountains
we go that's right Dean thanks for that
right that was amazing huh now I can't
wait for tomorrow even more Jake what's
up with our red well we've been shooting
with that thing for what three years oh
hey so Jake we're shooting so you know
that note that Ben got did that like
ever get resolved like I couldn't help
it over here you guys are still talking
about it well I have a few ideas but I
don't really my name names or anything
do you know what it's not my idea but
what if we did like some sort of like
beard competition like a beard off and
the loser has to shave it all like clean
shaven what's funny we thought of that
it was one of them out there was a tough
Nagle's idea yes think about it you're
here did you take your meds today
oh good competition really it's actually
not a bad idea